welcome back to Hannity now moments ago
I wrapped up an extensive wide-ranging
interview with former president Donald J
Trump here is part two of that interview
take a look
I want to talk about elections and I
agree with you and you mentioned at your
rally last night it's a position should
I share I would like to see election day
be a national holiday I would like
elections to be paper ballots making
exceptions for the military the sick the
elderly those exceptions they could
apply for an absentee ballot I would
like a national holiday
partisan observers in every Precinct
watching the vote all day long when the
polls close watching the vote counting
and at the end of the night you declare
a winner okay
it seems Democrats are more involved in
voting early they're more involved than
voting by a male and Most states most
people may not know this have legal
ballot harvesting it's been embraced by
the Democrats and not by the Republicans
there are states that are exceptions
like Florida
you know you have now changed your
position do you think that Republicans
reluctance and resistance to mail-in
ballots and voting early and ballot
harvesting like Democrats has that been
a mistake was that the mistake in 2022 I
never changed anything what I did is say
mail-in ballots are automatically
corrupt if you have mail-in ballots
you're going to have very dishonest
elections France had mail-in ballots
they had to go away from it they had an
election they went back to paper ballots
and by 10 o'clock in the evening
everybody was happy that it was
announced that was it paper you want
paper ballots you want same-day voting
ideally because you know we we have
elections where they sit around for 62
days big boxes of ballots they're laying
all over the floor you take a look at
what happened in Atlanta and some of
these other places but they're sitting
all over the floor they have
wheelbarrows carrying ballasts 62 days
in some cases so you have months of
Elections and people are saying what's
going on boxes are moving from here to
there it's ridiculous we should have
same-day voting we should have paper
ballots and we should have more voter ID
We're Not Gonna and signature
verification and chain of custody
controls and partisans but my question
is excuse me the Democratic voters want
it I hear 88 the people the Democrat
voters want it but the Democrat
politicians don't want so for 2024
should Republicans Embrace early voting
voting by mail and embrace the tactics
of the Democrats and follow the ballot
harvesting laws of their respective
States well they're going to have no
choice because we have to do it but if
you were running and you're like a nice
normal person who's doing a wonderful
job Who Wants To Be A congressman I
can't get elected president but what I'm
saying you agree with you no I don't I
don't know I think you could get elected
anything but and I think you do a
fantastic job thank you but if you were
running for office as a person that's
not very well known I mean the people
know me I think that's why I'm going up
during this hoax that's taking place in
New York and in by the way and with the
boxes hoax I mean how can you look at me
as an example with the boxes hugs and
they don't talk about Joe Biden where
his
1850 boxes of stuff where as a senator
he had all classified what about what
about as a senator he had all class of
Hillary Clinton and James Comey no
prosecutor would prosecute uh
unbelievable if you look back to that
that caused a tremendous problem within
the FBI you know I'm very happy about a
couple of things the actually I'm happy
because we can straighten this out in
this country this country is a mess
we're a mess I agree between inflation
the economy the what happened in
Afghanistan it started it because we
look so incompetent then Putin said wow
if they're that weak if they're that
incompetent this is the time to take
Ukraine don't forget he would have never
done that with me would have never done
it I want to get into that but let's
stay focused I want to stay on this last
part of this because I think this is
really very critical
um I mentioned Comey no prosecutor would
prosecute deleted emails right thirty
three thousand uh devices destroyed with
hammers SIM cards removed Hillary's
dirty dossier fisa warrants based on
that dossier that was 2016. now fast
forward to 2020. now you have FBI
they've had Hunter Biden's laptop since
December of 2019. we know thanks to the
New York Post and others the FBI was
having weekly meetings with big Tech you
referred to it a little bit earlier
warning them about potential
misinformation in the days leading up to
the 2020 presidential election now the
former head of the Twitter site of
Integrity in a case of Missouri he's now
now Senator Eric Schmidt then Attorney
General Eric Schmidt was involved in
specifically said that the FBI was
saying the misinformation it may be
about Joe Biden it maybe about Hunter
Biden so now they had this thing since
December 2019 they knew your lawyer Rudy
Giuliani had a copy that's right so they
knew it would likely be public and their
with the FBI is now telling big Tech
that this is likely going to be
misinformation that information then got
centered or censored across the board
okay explain that to me
so it's massive election interference
they said they knew it was the whole
thing with Russia because they knew by
that time that the dossier the famous
dossier was garbage it was made up by
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats and
the DNC the Democrats made it up it was
all made up they took this thing and
they sent it around to everything and it
was totally made up and now everybody
agrees to that
somebody should have been prosecuted for
that and you know what it should be this
group that does because now they have
all of the information go a step further
they spied on my campaign do you
remember I said a long time ago you know
I hear that they spotted my campaign and
at that time because truth is incredible
but at that time I was using Twitter now
I use truth although I have they want me
back on Twitter desperately are you
going to go back well we'll talk about
that at some point but I love truth I
think truth is incredible it's it's up I
think 389 it's the hottest thing there
is by the way Elon Musk revalued Twitter
at only 20 million well it was not uh 20
billion I'm sorry but he did a big favor
by letting people learn how corrupt our
government is because that's essentially
what it said but think of it so they go
in and they they are interfering the FBI
is interfering with an election and I'd
be willing to bet that the people that
work in the FBI the agents you know that
there is I would bet I'd have 90 of that
vote you but the top people when you
look at Comey he was just terrible did
you ever see the inspect and I had to
fire him and by the way I fired him very
early you know you're not a lot of
people say you can't really go so
quickly you got to go through a process
are you happy with Chris right but just
so you understand I put Chris Ray in
because I wanted to have somebody in
there that everybody including the other
side really wanted it may not have been
the right move let's see time will tell
okay but I wanted to have somebody in
the FBI because I'm an honorable guy I'm
an honest guy I may have made a mistake
but I put somebody in at the other side
everybody agreed to you know who
recommended him to me Chris Christie
okay he recommended him and that's okay
I don't mind that I've taken Chris
Christie's recommendations before uh and
other people wanted Christopher Ray and
people from the other side wanted
Christopher
is investigating though if the FBI is
politicized yeah I've interviewed two of
the whistleblowers there's going to
according to his committee dozens of FBI
whistleblowers and they're also looking
into the question and you brought up
these words last night the weaponization
of the Department of Justice total so
the question is so they had the laptop
since 2019.
they they could have easily verified it
within days I would imagine with the
technology uh advances they don't want
equipment okay they knew your lawyer
would likely leak it and FBI agents are
meeting weekly with big tax saying that
that might be misinformation by the way
the lawyer couldn't leak it because they
took it away from them they took it away
and you know they raided his apartment
and they took a lot of the things he
asked I don't know if they took that but
I think they took it away or they took
parts of it away but they rated a
lawyer's Rudy was a lawyer and is a
lawyer and a good one and you know
Rudy's been proven right about a lot of
things having to do with Ukraine and
others but
one thing I have to say lawyers I always
thought they were a little bit sacred
territory in other words if you're in
litigation the lawyers never brought in
I have every time somebody wants to
represent me or represent and I have a
lot of people that want to represent
because they think it's so unfair the
way we've all been treated but they end
up getting caught before grand juries
and stuff they end up getting sued
individually I say sometimes to a lawyer
are you sure you want to represent me I
think you're making a mistake what do
you need it for I have plenty of people
the good thing is I have plenty of
people with great spirit that do want to
represent me and we have some very very
good people but think of it lawyers for
the first time I've had lawyers that
I've known for a long time calling me
they said do you think this is changing
now where lawyers all of a sudden are
being sued for representing lawyers have
to come and reveal every conversation
with the client I've got that with the
boxes hooks I'll guarantee you Biden
doesn't have it and what he did with
classified information you know he has
stuff classified information when he was
a Senator and I've watched Senators I
want much Democrat senators get on
television and say I can't believe that
are you serious I don't believe that
question I can't I can't imagine you
ever saying
um bring me some of the boxes that we
brought back from the White House I'd
like to look at them did you ever do
that I would have the right to do that
there's nothing wrong with it I know you
I don't think you would do it well I
don't have a lot of time but I would
have the right to do that I would do
that let me move on let me remember this
this is the presidential records Act
I have the right to take stuff do you
know that they ended up paying Richard
Nixon I think 18 million dollars for
what he had they did the presidential
records act I have the right to take
stuff I have the right to look at stuff
but they have the right to talk and we
have the right to talk this would have
all been worked out all of a sudden they
raided Mar-A-Lago viciously rated
Mar-A-Lago I have tape and I gave them
tapes you know I gave them tapes of
storage areas I gave it to them I could
have held that back I wasn't holding
anything back that I cared about I gave
them tape but you know the tape they
don't want me to reveal if possible
they've asked me and I've I've so far
adhered to it
the rate itself
we have
I'll take that take and I'll air that
tape everybody would take that tape I'll
mask it first but no I have tape but
they think it might be dangerous because
of the faces and everything else and I
understand the good pixel amount but I
have tapes of the raid and the raid is
terrible and the way they treated people
is terrible and the way they treat
people now is unbelievable they ask
innocent people please go in and about
that but this is getting a job done what
they the way they treat people they
treat people like they're a foreign
country enemy hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else